what's going on everybody welcome to
part 11 of the Django web development
tutorials in this tutorial we're gonna
continue but not the last one and making
our tutorial page look a little better
than that so right now we have it at
least up to the point where the home
page shows categories we can click on
any of the categories and then we get
the tutorial series that match those
categories but let me click on the
tutorial series we get this so now what
we want to do is begin to set up the
URLs that work for tutorials themselves
so what we're gonna do now is pop on
over here and the first thing we need to
do is head over to our views dot pi I'm
also gonna get rid of this will keep
models in case I want to point to that
we don't need that and we'll keep
actually we're done with URLs DUP PI as
well so okay so we're gonna do our work
right in here and really we're gonna
just change this code here so this is if
the tutorial is inside of one of the
tutorial objects like if it matches one
of our tutorials hey we got a match so
what we want to do is we're gonna pass
basically that tutorial to the some page
we don't have it yet where we're gonna
render the tutorial stuff like a title
and big you know title font and then the
content and all that and then later
we'll even do a little sidebar because
it would be relatively simple to add in
actually that's probably the most
complex query
we're gonna make but it's okay it'll be
easy let's go so yes I've had my coffee
so what we're gonna do is start with if
so we know it is a tutorial so then all
we would want to say is if single slug
is in tutorials I'm trying to decide so
in this case we're actually matching the
URL I've wondered I'm trying to think if
there's some better way than referencing
all ever
Tom there's got to be a better way than
what I'm about to do I'm gonna go ahead
and do it this way but someone could
think of probably a way to only make
this call one time check for the slugs
and then later check you know get the
specific tutorial but anyway here we go
we're going to just run another query
basically and we're gonna say this
tutorial is equal to tutorial dot dot
get and then we're just gonna get we're
tutorial slug is equal to single slug so
all we're doing is just going through
these tutorial objects which loop here
tutorial loop and then single slug so we
match based on the slug which is why I
think hmm there's probably a better way
but we'll just do it this way for now
plus it gets us to write another query
and this will be like the easiest query
so we've had to write so anyway so we're
just finding the tutorial that matches
that slug so boom that gives us the
tutorial objects so in this case we use
a dot get as opposed to a dot filter so
yeah it's gonna get the object a filter
is gonna get a list of these objects
okay so we got this tutorial now what we
want to do instead is return render I
keep wanting to have a render template
that's from flask
anyway return render and we'll do
requests and then in this case the path
to the template so main slash this will
be tutorial dot T ml and then we pass
the context which in this case we're
gonna make its tutorial which links to
this underscore tutorial ok so now we
just need to make tutorial dot t ml easy
enough I'm tempted to copypasta this I
think I will there's really no good info
there and we can keep this shorter so
I'm going to continue with that
copypasta technique linked to this
tutorial is in the description or you
could type it but I just see it as a big
waste of time nothing new here so we're
going to go into main
templates mein you can really copy and
paste any of these I'm gonna copy a page
home I'm gonna call this now tutorial
tutorial okay
good spelled that right here we go a
tutorial here
okay so tutorial just as it does we're
going to extend the hetero HTML here's
our block content we're gonna make this
a row because I already know in advance
hey I'm going to include a sidebar so in
the case that the window size is very
small we're going to say hey take up the
entire grid otherwise if it's on a
medium screen or a large size screen
like a full screen like a desktop screen
hey take up eight columns so we can
reserve the other columns for the
sidebar you can feel free to tweak this
later but for now that's what we're
going to go with so then it displays the
tutorial title we give the published
publish time and these are in paragraph
tags but then for tutorial content since
we use one of those like what you see is
what you get editor's we just post up
the content and then use the safe flag
to display it we've been doing that
since the very beginning though so
nothing really new there so that's
refresh introduction to Python
programming but a boom but a bang you've
got yourself an intro to Python
okay so so we've done that the same
thing if we get like intermediate Python
there's your introduction to
intermediate Python very good so now we
want to do the sidebar so how do we get
so we want a couple of things first of
all we want to get all of the tutorials
from this series of the current tutorial
then what we want to do is it would be
nice we don't have to do this but it
would also be nice to denote where we
are currently like which one are we
looking at and kind of stick that out so
what I mean by that is if we go to real
Python permanent it if I like refresh to
this page the one that yeah this one is
the one we're currently on but then we
could click on this one and be like yeah
let's go go to that one okay so we can
do stuff like that so that's kind of
what I want to do here on like any
individual tutorial page I like to have
the sidebar here
so the way that we're gonna do that is
coming over to our views upon this
tutorial now what we want to say is man
my back is itchy this tutorial and then
I'm just trying to make it big as
possible this will be a long one it's
gonna run off the screen no matter what
size we do so what we're gonna say is
tutorials from series probably could
come up with a better name but we'll
stick with that we're going to say
tutorial DX dot filter filter so we're
going to filter by tutorial so first we
need to get the tutorial series
so tutorial underscore series now what's
tutorial series that tutorial tutorial
series is a foreign key so we already
should know that okay we're going to
point to tutorial series now if we want
to reference anything else under here
what we're gonna need to use is the
double underscore so what we will do
tutorials ears boom what we're trying to
reference here is we want to reference
the specifically the tutorial underscore
series where that tutorial series is
equal to this tutorial so again this is
a tutorial object well it has an
attribute tutorial series
hot-diggity let's so then we're just
gonna say this tutorial dot tutorial
series so take note the filter bits
where we're using like attributes is a
double underscore but then we're like to
get it to do the equals here is we're
back to Python land regular land I'd
love to know in the backend hey man I'd
love to know in the backend how that
double underscore even works like are
they using some sort of regular
expressions or is this an aspect of
Python I've never heard of I'd really
like to know I might have to go in the
back end and like
how they handled the that like what
exactly are they doing there cuz yeah
you'd want to use dot you know but no
that doesn't work so alright so filter
by a tutorial series but it we don't
just want because then then we can use
those to populate a sidebar button who
says that those are going to be in the
right order right it's important that
they're in the correct order so just
like we used dot earliest before I'll
just zoom out a little bit now just like
we use dot earliest to get the first
tutorial we can also dot order by Doug
banana and we can order by again
tutorial published boom so you can order
by that and then you could if you wanted
to reverse it you can either reversed or
colon colon negative one either those
should work anyway so now we've got the
tutorials that are a part of this series
and they are sorted for us finally one
more little thing that I'm going to grab
is this tutorial idx so we want the
index of this specific tutorial why do
we want that Centex glad you asked
Jeffrey the reason why we want that is
because we want to be able to pop out
which one is the one we're currently on
so we have to as we iterate over all of
the tutorials we need to know which one
which one are we trying to kind of like
highlight or pop out and so to do that
we're going to use the index so as we
iterate over we can also grab the index
I'll show you how in Django templating
and then when those two values equal
each other
boom that's the one we're gonna say is
the active bit in the sidebar
you're welcome Jeffrey so what we're
going to do this tutorial idx let's zoom
in again bring it back up to where
everybody can see this tutorial index
what we want to say here is going to be
list of or so we're converting to list
the two
tutorials from series boom and then
we're gonna grab dot the index of this
tutorial
tutorials so we're just getting the
index value of this specific tutorial by
converting the tutorial stuff to the
list
great ok tutorial this tutorial and then
what we're gonna add now to the context
is side sidebar sidebar will be
tutorials from series it's actually kind
of hard for me to see in this this size
it's probably not so bad for you guys
cuz it's probably you're viewing it much
smaller than me but it's hard for me to
see things anyway sidebar this tutorial
index that's so weird that I make it
that big and now I can't see it anyway
is this tutorial index so now we're
passing these three things to our
tutorial HTML page and again I'm gonna
copy pasta but what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna copy and paste it and I will
explain it completely for you guys so
I'm gonna do this oh my gosh I there we
go
okay now I'm gonna zoom out now it looks
like a lot of stuffs been added but most
of it is materialized stuff so so this
has not changed this is exactly what we
did before and then here we're adding in
the other remaining columns basically on
a small screen it'll just come it'll
just show below the above the tutorial
otherwise it'll be on those four four
remaining columns and then it's a UL
class collapsible pop-out that's a
materialized CSS specific class then
what we're doing here is for tutorial in
sidebar so tutorial in sidebar here
that's just all the tutorials in a
series which we ordered by tutorial
publish date so those should be we're
just assuming that's correct if for
whatever reason that isn't necessarily
always going to be correct for you you
can always go into the MA
and then add another parameter called
like part number or something like that
so you could later come in and edit
which part is which or something like
that and that's totally fine you could
sort by part number or order by part
number sorry not sort anyway hmm so I
know we were in tutorials HTML okay so
then so that's for every tutorial now
interestingly enough inside of any for
loop you can do this you can say if for
loop dot counter 0 you can like in
inside of any for loop in Django
templating you can use the variable hey
bro okay you can use the variable maybe
I can't but you could you can use for
loop counter and this will be a counter
starting at 1 so 1 2 3 4 but Python
doesn't start at 1 it starts at 0 so in
this case for loop counter you can say
for loop counter 0 and it will start at
0 this way you can make pretty lists and
stuff and you can do all kinds of fancy
stuff so super useful that that's there
that you can just say for loop counter
and you can use it as a parameter but
also in our case if those indexes match
up right if it's equal to this tutorial
index that we're saying this list
element is the active element therefore
we don't need a button to let go to it
basically otherwise the list element is
this bit in collapsible now I know you
guys are probably like wait wait wait
wait what's all this right this is the
collapsible stuff from materialized dot
CSS I'm not exactly sure where it is
probably actually in JavaScript because
it's actually uses JavaScript so yeah
jot so to go to the JavaScript area then
click collapsible and it makes stuff
like this right and you can do all kinds
of fun stuff with there collapsible so
you can feel free to change the
collapsible from what I am using as well
you don't have to use the exact same one
blah blah blah
tons of great information yeah you get
the idea so you can learn more about
collapsibles there if you
but just now basically I copy and pasted
their code and then through in my
modification to make it a four loop
inside of the collapsible unordered list
that's all I did
alright so save that and then let's go
to our website refresh boom we've got a
beautiful sidebar one thing you might
notice right away is the print function
I must I must have made a mistake
on this one I'm gonna argue an assert
that I I messed up I done goofed on part
two let's go back to the home page let's
go to data analysis yeah this may this
looks a little better I must have
accidentally pasted the tutorial into
the summary bit or something yeah I
don't know actually that's curious what
did I do
maybe into the title instead anyways
that's not important so cool
it's here but we we can't click on it
what's going on me and well again if
things aren't working press f12 reset
your your view in fact wow actually
we're not getting an error no error huh
I'm surprised that we're not getting the
error anyway I already know what's wrong
but really I guess I guess because what
we're doing is referencing the classes
so there is no error to be had I suppose
anyway we need to bring in some
JavaScript
you ruined my flow so we're gonna go to
header and what we need to bring in it
we need to initialize all of the
JavaScript so I'm trying to see here did
we initialize any because we have this
JavaScript but this isn't the same stuff
instead what we have to do is initialize
materialise which is something a little
different so when you import this
javascript it has some of the stuff that
you're going to need but if you want to
use some of their more fancy JavaScript
you have to initialize the materialized
CSS stuff so that's what we're going to
add here so
just underneath tiny MCE here I'm just
gonna add another set of script tags in
fact no I'm gonna add another set of
script tags and then what we're gonna
say here is m dot Auto in it boom and
that will initiate everything I bet if
we go here it'll tell us oh here
initialize this is what you would need
to initialize specifically this stuff so
actually this is either way you can use
jQuery or you could use regular
JavaScript I don't know a JavaScript
idiot so I don't know anyway someone
will comment below I'm sure anyway to
initialize you can either use that or
you can just initialize all the drop are
all of the materialized stuff cuz
there's a lot of stuff here that we're
gonna end up using anyways so you might
as well gate just initialize it I think
so
anyway you can do that and then we'll
come over here and I don't know where I
found that a little snippet it obviously
wasn't here it's somewhere though anyway
let's try to refresh again though close
this still for some reason we still
don't have the ones sticking out which
is curious to me but now we can click on
this and go at least I wonder I'm
curious to know why our if for loop
counter 0 what I'm gonna do is work to
talk hmm I hate to do this let me just
do this let's just do a quick variable
here paste I'm just gonna paste in the
current for loop counter ooh hold on how
how what in that work
oh we only did it for the active one duh
oh my gosh
that's our whole problem is we're not
seeing zero one two so it's definitely
working the next thing I'd like to know
is this tutorial index can I do I'm just
gonna throw head into maybe that's wrong
whoa okay so clearly that's must have
typo'd something this tutorial idx hmm
something is wrong index
this tutorial idx this detroit ex that
goes to here why I'm just not seeing
like anything on that page oh there we
go now we get to okay
why not in here though it's kind of
weird isn't it this tutorial ID eggs oh
okay that had to have been part of the
copy pasta right this idx oh my goodness
this is killing me because this okay so
I didn't I wrote this code out I'm not
so stupid dad it's just dumb anyway then
so but in my text-based version I
actually call this variable this T UT ID
X who dummy okay so our issue is pretty
simple we were calling the variable this
so this variable here this never existed
so now let me do this delete those big
dummy dummy alright save that so we
fixed that tutorial link there over here
refresh it works good job everybody
okay so finally now if I go to like this
one for example boom it knows hey you're
on that one and then I could go to this
one boom it knows we're on that one
we did it whoa okay and then by the way
if we continue to squish this in word
write this now becomes more fullscreen
and then if we scroll all the way to the
bottom we see okay now it's down here
okay well I think this is a good
stopping point I actually thought this
would go much faster
I don't know how long this video is
gonna be everything's been like over 20
minutes and I keep not believing that
it's been that long
questions comments concerns whatever
feel free to leave them below otherwise
if you feel so inclined you could check
out that beautiful blue button right
over there look at that I bet it food
feels so good if you just clicked on
anyway that's all for now I think in the
next video I'm gonna focus on deployment
not exactly sure how I want to do that
cuz there's like easy ways and there's
hard ways to do the deployment so I
might let it hang for a little bit and
see what most people want so I can
either provide a script that you can
just run and it sets everything up so
you can run the script on like a boon
too and it just sets it up wherever you
want to host it and I'll show you guys
setting up hosting and stuff like that
more we could do it the hard way
where we do like everything on video
like I could go through like the script
and tell you like here's what's
happening but we don't have to type it
out and wait or we could type out
literally everything but that would take
probably like 4 videos or more so I'm
just not really sure which way I want to
do it so if you have an opinion feel
free to leave it below as far as what
you know what do you want to see when we
actually do a deployment and then also
there's like other things that you need
to like look through like with Django
like your your key and how you're gonna
handle static and media and all this
stuff there's lots of little stuff but
I'm tempted to use a script instead just
because for most people I'm not really
sure the setup prophets like a thing
you're just gonna do one time and then
in the future you would just use the
script like I'm really excited to have
this script because I don't need to type
all this stuff in any more so anyway and
then we could at least talk about the
script just in case something changes
down the line but easy way or hard way
let me know down below otherwise that's
it for now questions comments concerns
suggestions whatever feel free to leave
them below otherwise I'm gonna see you
guys in another video